it's nhl all-star weekend events start
today at the fan fair inside the las
vegas convention center i had a chance
to go there and check it out myself
there's a bit of a rumor going around
that i'm a hockey nerd
not exactly sure where that idea comes
from but if you are a hockey nerd this
is the place to go wednesday work was
still underway inside the west hall i
caught up with fellow hockeyist nick
generelli he oversees fan fest for the
nhl obviously the golden knights are so
popular here but to bring the whole
league the all-star game all the best
players all the names all the heritage
to las vegas well we're excited to be
here ever since uh we announced that the
vegas golden knights would be the 31st
franchise we knew we wanted to do an
all-star game here this fan base has
become you know so attached to the team
and we love that and we're thrilled to
be uh to be offering nhl fanfare for the
fans here you can buy gear you can give
hockey a try yourself you can learn all
about the great players of today or dig
into the nhl's past all 19 of the
league's awards are on display gordy
howe bernie jeffrion jacques plant
jean beliveau just some of the famous
names from hockey's past that are there
that is the heart trophy that is given
to the most valuable player and as you
can see it's one of the awards that you
can see right here at fan fest wearing a
helmet and gloves is not mandatory and
on this stage is where the most
important part of all professional
hockey will be
this is the stage where you will get to
see the one and only stanley cup people
who want to take part how do they get in
what what else will they get to enjoy
well for the first time ever we're going
to have a watch party for both the
skills on friday and for the all-star
game on saturday so if they're not lucky
enough to have a ticket to that event at
t-mobile arena they'll be able to come
down here watch it on our large screens
hear the audio and be able to enjoy it
with uh with fans and
well at some point all of us will get a
chance to do the hardest shot
competition as well yes so so just like
the pros we will have a couple skills
here that they're participating in like
harder shot and accuracy challenge
all right well the music is playing i
guess that means we got to wrap it up
nick thank you very much for showing us
herrera appreciate it pleasure enjoy the
weekend all-star weekend in las vegas